[Musique]
il y a très longtemps cette chandelle a
offert miracle à notre famille sa magie
à donner vie à notre nid maison notre
cas si
aulas kassid
[Musique]
le temps venu chaque membre de notre
famille
reçoit son propre double magique
je suis pas une force de la nature comme
luiz lula sont encore dehors
ni naturellement parfaite comme señorita
pulp et à isabelle
l'imamat pourquoi suis-je la seule à
n'avoir aucun dos tu es aussi
exceptionnel que n'importe quel membre
de cette famille
tu viens de guérir maman avec ou
n'avaient pas compté son
cas site
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il
la magie est en danger devant partir
nous devons protéger notre maison
d'offres protéger notre famille
c'est ma seule chance juste sauverait la
machine attendez vous comment sauve la
magie
mirabel l'avenir de la famille dépend
entièrement de droit
j'y arriverai jamais
vers midi les rames lundi tous les
secrets ne les mangent pas
dans les pierres moment
la lumière revient
quand on s'y attend le
[Musique]
oh
tout s'est mal mais ce qui compte c'est
que j'ai un ami enfin j'ai cru que
j'avais un ami la soeur
tout est arrivé très vite
une éruption solaire
adieu récoltes et nourriture à dieu tout
alors je me suis caché
terrifié et tellement seul
et puis je t'ai trouvé
bon qu'est-ce qu'on commande s'il te
plaît enlève t'écoute de la table enlève
tes gouttes de la taille bon allez à toi
tu vois je suis en train de travailler
sur un truc intéressant sorte d'acte de
foi gier
si tu peux parler dis moi quelque chose
qui te concerne robot doit protéger
tiens
si on ne porte pas avant que la tempête
éclate on our à tous dès que tu sais
marcher on s'en va 1 2
ça c'est tombé
[Musique]
droit vers l'ouest à travers les
montagnes aimerais-tu que je conduis ne
braque pas trop c'est trop gros qui lève
le pied est plus un poil
parfait
[Musique]
cette fois ce boucan japon à part les
chiens
je ne crois pas qu'il m'aime
ça
arinc en pin cas
cette fois quelque chose
[Musique]
devrait être en sécurité quand on sera
dans les montagnes les jo ce terrible
vont se produire
une température de 65 degrés
un rayonnement ultraviolet et des êtres
humains qui se cachent dans l'emploi à
l'époque
c'est quoi qu'on n'y arrivera pas sans
mon équipe
ce qu'on fait on le fait ensemble
je crois en toi
[Musique]
je vais être franc avec toi molly et
ruina taux de rechute de 97% c'est la
quinzième fois que tu vis ça
est-ce que vous connaissez les
antagonistes des opiacés on ne fait une
injection par ward injection immunisés
contre les effets de la drogue
c'est sans danger
tu te fous de moi d'un seul quoi tu dois
protéger ton petit corps tu peux rester
clean pendant au moins une semaine coin
encore quatre jours c'est rien
on a déjà subi beaucoup de choses j'ai
peur pour toi tu es qu'elle se trouve
dans les parages fait et qui si j'étais
pas une junkie tu me demanderait même
pas probablement vie toutes les fois où
j'ai renoué avec elle je l' ai toujours
fait en pleine connaissance qu'au fil
ils veulent aussi
je veux plus vaillants
maman comment elle est elle reste assise
à fumer et à trembler je suis là la
surveiller toute la journée tout en
faisant comme si je ne le faisais pas
cela fait presque une journée
[Musique]
il n'en reste plus que trois
je suis désolé j'aurais tellement voulu
être s'arrêter mif tu crois que c'est ma
faute si tu te croquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh mon dieu
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'une durée et du ray
vendus désolé je ma dépendance à la
drogue soit aussi difficile à vivre pour
toi parfois j'ai l'impression
je préférerais ne plus l'aimer
il a tout vous savez combien de fois je
me suis dit qu'il n'était pas question
que je vole pour de la drogue je
voudrais parfois que ce soit plus facile
pour elle qu'il était pas question que
je perde la garde de maisons fort pour
de la drogue
tout
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir chapelle loire attendre encore
au vietnam et au maire
je suis désolé à voir
s'il ya une personne qui a la force se
libérer de cette merde c'est toi ça j'en
suis sûr je suis fier de toi
[Musique]
l'américaine lisa et moi on va faire un
sochalien j'ai besoin d'un break
home sweet home
[Musique]
c'est pas ton n'exclut pas une bonne
raison de me tuer au moins déjà pour
commencer le fait que tu aies te faire
sauter ailleurs c'en est une me tords
pas du tout
c'est idiot ton plan était bio toi même
tu es un idiot rien d'étonnant
finalement trois mois par contre
ah ah
tu m'as tu irais dans l'anus
vous êtes sous les cris on a faussé
compagnie aux matons qui nous
surveillait
on va ce côté ici le temps de se faire
gentiment oblige on n'a pas terminé
fust et on
d'accord
oui
qu'est ce que t'as foutu l'ars
et créa quelle merveilleuse initiative
d'avoir proposé un cristal de passer le
week end avec mirabaud alex lutz a trois
passions dans la vie les chevaux
l'humour
et la télé des années 60 à 90 pays un
venez dans mon monde après stéréo top et
guy au cinéma il est de retour dans une
nouvelle création originale
délicieusement vintage
inspiré d'un sauf des années 80 la
vengeance au triple galop revisite avec
brio les codes du genre pour moi c'est
vraiment une parodie hommage est pas une
parodie moqueuse
j'adore c'est surtout le côté parodie
c'est à dire de prendre le code et de
l'otan je me sers un scotch de la veille
de scotch en floride on avait souvent
des personnages qui se parlent sans se
regarder ça c'est des trucs qu'ils
faisaient dans les séries mais qui est
complètement absurde ménagez vous fige
on est très sensible à l'étalonnage des
images au mix du son travail de son et
d'image mélanger c'était des voix de
doublage qui faisait dans ces séries là
donc ça sonne un peu bizarre au labo
henderson
aspects fiscaux
dans le rôle de l'héroïne audrey lamy
interprète une jeune héritière quelque
peu naïve que cela vous plaise nous nous
sommes un couple d'amoureux transis la
grande naïve mais attention
la roue tourne j'ai moi même une
revanche à prendre sur l'homme
un casting cinq étoiles dans débrouille
on décoiffante il ya deux choses que je
sais reconnaître dans la vie les pousses
crème de jour et les vrais crimes de
sang alors comment j'ai réussi à
convaincre ces gens là j'espère on leur
disant bien déjouer avec nous dans notre
truc appelé mobile
non la toussaint je pense qu'on peut
faire il préfère cette clameur là pour
le coup on est vraiment des enfants qui
jouent on a toutes les références avec
lesquels on a grandi en fait
je
[Musique]
c'est un personnage qu'on a extirpé du
groupe modern talking
on a le droit d'en faire des tonnes on
en a même le devoir
à jouer c'est un kiff mais mental tu
joues en douze jours ce que une actrice
rêve de jouer en une carrière ça peut
vraiment elle passe d'un truc d'un
opposé à l'autre en très peu de temps
signés ces documents
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas de
stylo comme son nom un jour c'est une
histoire de vengeance et comme dans
toutes ses sagas tout est dit mais tu
regardes quand même et nous avons besoin
d'un stylo nous n'en avons pas
[Musique]
pâques
ok ça vaut qu'à ma grande jupe adam tour
non moi j'ai ma cousine qui habite là
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu emménager te
connais tu ne les crains qu artiste
crasseuse peut-être que je ne croise les
dossiers alors
[Musique]
à la ronde il fait bon jour mais s'ils
bougent pas et c'est une autre borne
basse parlez-moi correctement c'est vrai
que je
commence à ce courrier écrit thomas
va cesser piétiné comme ça ou quoi on
apprend tout avec un mec
finissent à la réputation du direct
arrête attendait de compte
stocker malades de
la honte là et tu me dis que tu es
désolé c'est ça
[Musique]
la classe soit se peut
et
ça je crois pas je comprends pas moi
votre génération vous vous irez coran
toutes les 100 minutes quand on arrive
en france où chercher la liberté
est sûr qu'un jour tu me ramènes un beau
jeune homme
j'y crois bien géré cette hilarante
existe plus pour mon second
[Musique]
te
nous voudrions aussi savoir quel sera le
premier choix de gardien de but pour
notre équipe nationale
je pense qu'il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un
doute là dessus
le gardien de but de l'équipe nationale
sera yacine mais toi ça fait vite leur
fille chine
[Applaudissements]
valia
l'efs
il a reçu les honneurs des maîtres
d'espoir et de son équipe il s'agit de
la vie en chine le real madrid est un
grand club mais je suis trop attaché au
cinéma
comme ça notre pays pour être fiers de
vous
le montant qui sera qui vous êtes
donc vous là dehors
on
n'a pas besoin d'un autre commis tch
le football
c'est vivant
ce n'est jamais pareil c'est une
perpétuelle évolution
je te comprends pas le diovan tu as de
bonnes mains t'es pas un imbécile
pourquoi tu as besoin de ce fou du foot
il faut que quelqu'un paie
pour la défaite de notre équipe
la chine a fait son temps voilà
iasi et une combe dont l'équipe
c'est une football les anciens exploits
sans combat ce sont les résultats
actuels qui importe
quand tu joueras pour l'équipe nationale
alors n'oublie jamais que tu n'es pas
juste là pour attraper une balle on
y lit à ton pays derrière toi
la batterie est là alcante
elle compte sur toi
tâche de lui faire honneur
vous êtes ga chine c'est moi oui est ce
que vous pourriez le prouver